There is a specialist for
each of these body systems.
A cardiologist for the heart.
A pulmonary specialist for the lungs.
An endocrinologist for diabetes.
And an internist to manage hypertension.
Unless Marla develops a particularly
severe issue, a PCP might manage
all of these problems,
with occasional help from a specialist.
Since she doesn't have a PCP,
she ends up just seeing specialists.
Unless things change, this trend toward
specialty care is projected to grow.
By now you're probably wondering
why this is a problem.
Primary care physicians have been shown
to deliver similar quality to
specialists for certain conditions,
such as diabetes and hypertension,
often while using fewer resources.
They often provide better
preventative care than specialists,
reflecting their ability to better
manage the whole health of patients and
can help reduce hospitalization rates.